Welcome, everybody, to this
evening's conversation,
The Loss of Green,
Imaging Vegetal Worlds,
hosted by the MIT Wiesner
Student Art Gallery
current artist and organized
by her, Nancy Valladares.
My name is Sarah Hirzel.
Hi, Nancy.
I'm the coordinator
of the gallery.
For anyone who has any
questions or interest
in the gallery in the
future, please let me know.
We will put a link to
the gallery in the chat.
Before Nancy introduces her
partners, Semine Long-Callesen
and Shireen Hamza, I
want to invite everyone
to submit questions for the Q&A
using the chat function, which
we'll read later.
Please keep your microphone
muted during the event when
our speakers are having
their conversation,
but later, there'll be a
chance in the Q&A for everyone
to participate.
And we really encourage you to
use the Raise Hand button, come
on screen, and we look forward
to a lively conversation.
Without further ado, I'd
like to warmly welcome
Nancy Valladares, Semine
Long-Callesen, and Shireen
Hamza.
Thank you so much, Sarah.
Thank you, everyone,
for coming to the talk.
So The Loss of Green, Imaging
Vegetal Worlds is part of--
Sarah mentioned
the online exhibit
that I was invited to do
at the Wiesner Gallery.
Thank you so much, Sarah,
for all your support
and to all the staff members
who made this possible.
So I'm just going to give a
very brief description of what
the work is, because there was
already a gallery walk through,
which will be made
available shortly.
And also, the link to the show
will be put in the description
at some point, which you're
more than welcome to go and take
a look at it.
But so my work was--
the specific project,
Botanical Ghosts,
was part of a
three-year investigation
into the agricultural histories
and botanical histories
of Honduras, specifically in
Lencetilla Botanical Gardens,
which is located
in the north coast.
And my art practice is a
multidisciplinary offering
for botanical imaginaries.
And my thought of
this practice is
as a metabolism through which
internal becomings can happen.
And today, I have the honor
of moderating this talk
between Semine and Shireen.
I'm very excited
for the conversation
that will take place today.
So first up, I would
like to introduce Semine.
Semine Long-Callesen
is a historian
who recently received her
master's in architecture
studies in the history,
theory, and criticism of art
and architecture department
from MIT in 2020.
Semine's work examines
colonial national museums
in Denmark, Malaysia,
and Singapore,
as well as contemporary
artistic practices that
respond to such institutions.
She holds a BA in art
history with distinction from
the University of Cambridge,
and she was also a [? Fialkov ?]
fellow and a [? Paulson ?]
researcher at MIT,
and is currently a fellow at
the Currier Museum of Art in New
Hampshire, as well as a
researcher at the Mexico
City-based architecture
practice, [INAUDIBLE]..
Her research has been
published in the Journal
of the Malaysian Branch
of the [? Roja ?] Asiatic
Society and the Danish National
Gallery's Perspective Journal.
And today, Semine
will share with us
both part of her research and
her recipe website, Garden
Blues, which is a personal
iteration of the work
that she's done in the archive.
And Shireen Hamza is a historian
and a current PhD candidate
in history of science
at Harvard University.
Her dissertation project
is a reassessment
of the concept of
Islamic medicine
by studying scholarly
medical traditions
across the Indian Ocean world.
Working on texts of both Galenic
and Ayurvedic medicine composed
in Arabic and Persia between--
in Arabic and Persian between
the 13th and 15th centuries,
she shows the coexistence
of, and exchange between,
multiple traditions
of healing, as well as
the transformation
of disease categories
and medicinal substances
in Yemen and Gujrat.
Her work has been supported
by the Social Science Research
Council and the
Fulbright Commission,
and she's the managing editor
for The Ottoman History
Podcast, and wrote and
produced Ventricles,
a podcast on science
outside of the West.
So I would like to just talk a
little bit about the thoughts
behind organizing this talk
and why Semine and Shireen--
I had the privilege of being
in conversation with them
and this coming
together really fluidly.
And the dialogue between us
spans several geographies
and temporalities, and
this [INAUDIBLE] thing
of botanical exchanges,
sensory encounters
and archival histories
lie the practices
of Shireen and Semine,
whose work I deeply admire
and have been inspired by.
The title of this talk
comes from an essay
published by Prudence
Gibson on the color green.
And I wanted to read to you
a very small excerpt where
she writes.
"It is due to the loss of green
from our everyday habitats
that greenness is more
than a hue of nostalgia.
It has also become a keen
political weapon, an activated
and dynamic arena of
civic and civil debate.
Thinking green is the same
as thinking for the long now.
Our plans and concepts need
to have longevity and long
distance strategic clout."
So to me, this phrase, this
title, The Loss of Green,
invokes the presence of
an ecological past, what
Anna Tsing and Donna
Haraway referred
to as the plantation
[INAUDIBLE],,
which has been ongoing
through negotiations
of what is considered to
be living and non-living.
In some ways, my
desire for this talk
was to look at this
ecological present
and speculate on the
future through the lens
of this vegetal past.
What does the now look
like after centuries
of hybridizations,
of bioprospecting,
and of the ongoing extractive
relationships between humans
and the vegetal world?
Both Semine and
Shireen's practices
unearthed knowledge through
different sensoriums,
from the sense of
taste and smell
and the various
cuisines that make
their appearance in Semine's
project, Garden Blues,
to Shireen's engagement
with descriptions of plants
and medicinal practices
through the written word.
Beyond solely images,
both of their work
take on the role of
animating the specimens
and manuscripts in the archive.
What drew me to their
respective practices
was how they engage with the
affect of these repositories,
challenging and blurring
the roles of the historian
and the witness.
So please welcome both
Semine and Shireen.
I am going to hand it over
to our first presenter, which
I believe is Semine,
if I'm not mistaken.
So I'm just going to hand
it over to you, and welcome.
Hi, everyone, and thank
you for joining us tonight.
It's so good to
see so many friends
and familiar faces,
and new ones, too.
Nancy, thank you
for the introduction
and for inviting me to be here.
I'm excited to talk
with you and Shireen
and share my thoughts with you
guys and with everyone else.
So as Nancy mentioned,
my work focuses mostly
on British colonial history and
colonial history in Malaysia,
or Malaya as it was known.
And I've looked specifically
at colonial museums
during the 19th century.
They existed in most places
in the British empire
and were large repositories of
mineral and plant specimens.
And the museums were important
to colonial administration,
because they functioned
as laboratories
that worked in the service of
a general search for revenue.
So in Malaysia, these
museums carried out
botanical experiments
with rubber and palm oil,
and eventually, these cash
crops transformed the landscape
of Malaysia and turned it into
a very lucrative colony of one
of the main exporters of
rubber and oil, palm oil.
So curiously, later
in the 20th century,
museums came to play a role
of guardians of nature.
They spearheaded conservation,
nature conservation
as nature was disappearing
outside the museum
walls due to the industries
that the museums themselves
had engineered.
So the museum has
this double role
of both destroying
and preserving.
And the colonial museum
also became a mirror of self
for specific parts of
the independence movement
in Malaysia.
So they were initially part of
a big colonial infrastructure
that rendered Malaya
readable and exploitable
and governmental.
But these collected
artifacts and specimens
of natural history
were also adopted
by nationalist
movements, and they
came to represent a
distinct national identity.
So thoughts about colonial
botany and industries
and identity has been
on my mind for a while.
And when I met Nancy
a couple of years ago
and we started cooking
together, we're realizing that--
we realized that there were
a lot of overlapping flavors.
And this was a surprise
to me, because in my head,
Honduras is very far
away from Malaysia.
But as we dug into the
history of these places,
we realized that
there were lots of--
the similarities were due to
the geographies being ports
in the same imperial networks.
So Honduras and Malaysia
are not formally or fully
part of the same
empires, but people
like Dorothy Popenoe
and Wilson Popenoe, who
are the protagonists,
so to speak,
in Nancy's "Botanical Ghosts,"
her artwork, these two figures
were American and British
explorers and discoverers
who traveled to
Malaysia and Honduras
and documented plant species
there and carried with them
seeds from one botanical
station to another
across the tropical belt.
So from my experiences
with cooking with Nancy and
from working in the archive
emerged a more poetic
iteration of my research work.
It's a recipe website
called Garden Blues,
which is inspired by Honduran
and Malaysian cuisine.
And I'm going to share
with you my screen
so you can see the website.
OK.
So I should say that,
in creating this site,
I've received a lot of
help, especially from Agnes
Cameron, who built it
with me and who thought
with me about its story.
So big thank you to Agnes.
So the landing site is a
bunch of gardens and rivers
that are named after memories
and themes and places.
And each garden and river
is populated by flowers
or wavy little squiggles.
And if you click on a
flower, it will take you
to a recipe that's associated
with the theme of the place.
So if we go to the Taiping
Lake Gardens, which
is in the north of
Malaysia, a recipe
for this coconut pan
fried cake will come up.
And if we go to a Garden
of Cash Crops down here,
a recipe for the beloved
plantains will come up.
And then lastly, if we go
to the Garden of Blues,
another dessert will come up.
So this site also has an
index with the list of recipes
and a writing blog where
I think about the theory
and the histories that
is behind this site.
So through food, I
think this recipe site
tells a story about
itinerant colonial nature
that travel through the tropics.
And it also tells the
story about hybridity.
I think it's a pushback against
nationalist ideas of where
things belong.
It's a pushback
against authenticity,
and personally,
it's also disturbing
the lines between what we
think of as local and foreign.
And I think, in that way,
it's a reflection of what
it means to come
from a territory that
is much larger than the
countries that we grew up in.
So that's it for me now.
I'm going to pass the
spotlight to Shireen
and stop screen sharing.
Thank you.
Thank you, Semine.
Thank you so much, Semine.
That was so, so
interesting, and I
can't wait for the discussion.
So I'm a historian of Medicine
in the medieval Indian--
or sorry, the medieval
Islamic world,
a time before European empires
shaped, and were shaped by,
capital S science.
And I spend my days reading
manuscripts written out
over the centuries by physicians
who lived in the regions
bordering the
Indian Ocean world.
The manuscripts that
you see here all
feature descriptions of
plants in alphabetical order,
or rather, those
parts of plants that
were most relevant to medicine.
So physicians needed to know
the therapeutic application
of these parts.
But with the exception of
those few who actively foraged
and studied botany,
they did not encounter
plants growing in their
environments as wholes.
Foragers, farmers,
traders, they were
the ones who supplied
markets with the dried roots,
stems, leaves, flowers, resins,
powders that were actually
used by physicians.
And these processed
forms of the plant
could travel, whether
to local markets
or to those across the ocean.
While there was a more
rarefied tradition
of illustrated
botanical manuscripts,
even these centered human uses
of, and relations to, plants.
They never claimed to
offer a universal system
of classification.
The descriptions
that you see here
included information on
where the plant grows,
its different variants, the
color of its usable parts
and their taste and
smell in relation
to other medicinal substances.
These were a practical
set of comparisons.
But when I close my
eyes and try to picture
the history of botany,
I don't actually
imagine the millions of extant
pages of Arabic and Persian
manuscripts in libraries
across Eurasia and the US.
I see instead the bright
illustrated plant typologies
of European colonial
botany, which
I have encountered as
framed prints hung up
on the walls of countless
inns, cafes, and shops.
The more history
I learn, the more
sinister my encounters with
these aestheticed forms
have felt, erasure
after erasure.
As historian, Daniela
Bleichmar, has argued,
efforts to make the empire
visible always made parts of it
invisible.
The authors were those
who could lay claim
to the intellectual
work of observing
and classifying, writing it
all down in colonial languages.
Unmentioned were those
doing the manual labor
of procuring the specimens or
of painting their portraits.
Nancy's work in
"Botanical Ghosts"
brilliantly evokes the
macabre lives and afterlives
of these images, made
by people who, quote,
"chose to accept the
death of many things."
18th century naturalists
aspired to represent plants
as more real than reality,
a generalized typology,
accessible only with great
skill and difficulty.
They were intentionally
and aggressively selective,
extracting the typical
from the particulars
of individual
specimens, not, quote,
"distracted by irrelevant
details and accidental traits,
a leaf torn by an insect, a
wilting flower, or a flower
not fully bloomed."
Historians, Lorraine
Daston and Peter Galison
call this kind of
knowing truth to nature.
Idealized botanical
images had a generality
that transcended the
species to, quote,
"reflect a never seen,
but nonetheless real,
plant archetype."
But as Bleichmar and Londa
Schiebinger have argued,
this kind of botanical
expertise was so highly valuable
in the 18th century,
where botany was, quote,
"big business and big science."
Botanical expeditions
were expensive,
deploying large teams
of naturalists, artists,
and laborers, and requiring
the active participation
of a whole imperial
administrative apparatus,
governors, treasury officials,
physicians, pharmacists,
clergymen and many
other local populations,
town to town in the Americas.
Botanical images were implicated
in their investors' desires
for future profit.
Economic botany shaped the
fate of uncountable plants
and people who were commodified
within a plantation economy.
The violent ends to which
these images contributed
are another major difference
from the medieval traditions
of botany and
pharmacopeia that I study.
Nancy transforms idealized
illustrations of the ackee tree
into a uniformly gray
rotating 3D model,
gesturing at the
continuity of truth
to nature in contemporary
cultures of scientific modeling
and de-familiarizing these
ubiquitous and highly
aestheticized illustrations.
In the narrative of "Botanical
Ghosts," I witnessed
Dorothy's senses heighten,
her boundaries of self
dissolve into the specificity of
Lencetilla's lives and deaths.
In imagining this intensely
local story in Dorothy's lives,
the sense of "thereness"
that Nancy describes, and--
sorry.
In imagining this intensely
local story in Dorothy's life
and the sense of
"thereness" that she felt,
Nancy evokes a time scale
that transcends that of empire
and challenges the
totalizing universal way
of seeing and classifying that
the Linnaean system proposed.
Truth to nature images
often divorced plants
from the environment
where they grow
and the culture and
knowledge of the people
who cultivate or
forage them, quote,
"rejecting the
local as contingent,
subjective, and translatable,
favoring instead
the dislocated
global as objective,
truthful, and permanent."
A lot changed from
the composition
of these medieval medical
texts in the 14th century,
to Carl Linnaeus and the 18th,
to Dorothy Popenoe in the 20th.
But I was really surprised to
find a moment of recognition
in this sentence of the
narrative of "Botanical
Ghosts."
"Dorothy told
herself she was not
one to believe in spirits,
especially the ones
that she heard about among
the workers of Lencetilla."
Though learned medieval
sciences were not
as totalizing as the modern
sciences have become,
nor as separate or
privileged within hierarchies
of knowledge,
their practitioners
still policed the boundaries
of their disciplines.
While farmers, miners,
traders, and foragers
had valuable knowledge
physicians and botanists relied
on to learn local
particulars and to locate
beneficial plant, animal,
and mineral substances,
their names only seldom
enter the texts as sources
and do not have the
same prestige as those
of ancient textual authorities.
Though, these relationships
were quite different from that
of Dorothy's to the
workers on Lencetilla
the continuity of
scientific exclusion
was one that I was
unprepared to face.
Nancy does not dwell on this
racist and classist violence
in Dorothy's discourse.
She mentions it
somewhat obliquely,
privileging instead the
voice of the ackee tree
and Dorothy's terrifying
and transformative encounter
with it.
At a recent Union Docs event,
artist, Madeleine Hunt-Ehrlich,
spoke about abstraction as a
form of opacity and opacity
as a strategy used
by Black artists
as a way to protect
themselves and their audiences
from historical violence.
This struck me as an
apt way of understanding
Nancy's engagement with the
colonial archive of botany
in Honduras.
She still makes
images to mediate
something of this
visual past, however
opaque the transmission.
But it is a history
thoroughly haunted
by the radical
vibrancy of plants.
Thanks.
Thank you so much, Shireen
and Semine, both of you,
for these really amazing
and incredible presentations
of your work.
I'm very excited to start to
just jump into the discussion
so we have as much
time as we can.
But I really--
I wanted to have--
maybe start out with a
question that both of you
could answer about your
experiences as historians.
And I would really like
to know a little bit more
about the sensory and
affective experiences
that you've both experienced
in these different archives
and repositories and the kind of
things that do not get written
into the academic texts and
these kind of projects that
are, I think, challenging
these boundaries again
of historian/witness.
And I would like to enter
the conversation there,
so I was wondering if
one of you could jump in.
And we could do just unmute and
get the conversation flowing.
I can start.
Yeah, it's interesting how
behind the writing of history,
there is a lot of
archive work that
goes into producing text, which
is not necessarily included.
I think something that I didn't
mention in my presentation,
and that also doesn't come
through in the recipe website,
is that in the natural
realm, included people.
And anthropological
studies of people
were also appearing
in studies of plants.
So there is this curious--
the British natural history
includes both locals,
different races and religion,
what today is categorized
as cultural artifacts.
But then, in the early colonial
museums in the 19th century,
these were
categorized as nature.
And I was speaking
to this a little bit
in this idea of
the colonial museum
transitioning into
the national museum.
So the natural resource,
both labor and nature,
later on becomes
this mirror of self.
Like locals see
themself mirrored
in natural history museums.
The natural resource
becomes this--
enters the cultural
realm, it becomes
like a cultural resource.
Yeah.
No, that's so interesting.
And, Semine, when
you were talking
about the porosity of
different empires and how,
even though your
two family histories
may be filed away into
two separate empires,
I thought that was
really interesting how
they come together, in
the kitchen, at least,
and how we can't
really just study
Spanish empire or British
empire as two separate things.
But I also loved
to hear what you
said about the relationship
between museums
and conservation and
the kind of temporality
of the past, the idea of
salvage that animated so much
of anthropology.
And I'd love to
hear, at some point,
you say more about what
role museums did play
in this idea of conservation.
But yeah, I wanted to
answer Nancy's question
by talking about where all those
manuscript images you guys saw,
where I encountered them.
And it was all in the UK
and online World Digital
Library or Yale University's
Beinecke Library.
These are all
places really diff--
far and removed from
the context where
these manuscripts were written.
So when I go to, say, the
British Library's Oriental
Studies reading room, which is
full of these portraits of, I
don't know, major people
in British colonial history
from Asia and Africa, it
feels so strange to me.
There was a moment when I was
there during my dissertation
research where there's a
manuscript of a 14th century
pharmacological and medical
text [INAUDIBLE],, which
is a Persian text.
And the British
Library has a copy
of this text copied
by the author's son.
So it's really close
to the author's life
and this very kind
of a precious object.
And I don't know how many
people ever really order
it or want to see it.
But if it was in a
different context,
I think there would
be a lot of people
who would be really happy
to be able to access
that manuscript somewhere,
maybe where Persian is spoken.
And so those things
happen every day.
And it's so strange to be--
to know-- to recognize that the
knowledge system I'm studying
is hierarchical--
I'm not trying to idealize it.
But to just be--
to look at in the
face every day,
that this is removed
from its context,
either by theft or by
purchase under duress,
or any number of ways that
these manuscripts make
their ways into these
libraries and archives,
and then to balance that with
the moments of discovery,
moments of, oh this is
so great for my research,
to feel happy while
handling these manuscripts,
it feels very like
competing moments.
And that's why I
really connected
with that aspect of your
project, Nancy, this
entering an archive of
violence but finding
very human narratives and
constructing and speculating
as to the subjectivity
of those people,
rather than just
shutting it out.
Right.
Yeah, thank you
so much, Shireen.
And I mean, I think
that something else
that I thought that both
of your works were doing
was also challenging very
much the ways in which
the construction of
nature was happening
through different senses.
And I briefly mentioned
in the introduction,
and, Semine, yours, it's through
this exchange of flavors,
and tastes, and smells,
and cuisines that
was happening, and,
Shireen, through these--
the descriptions of plant
species and medicinal practices
that require a certain,
perhaps, other kind of knowledge
that is--
I don't know if it exists
any longer or doesn't.
But, Semine, I was curious
whether there was any way
in which these readings or
expansions of the senses when
it comes to imagining
vegetal imaginaries,
what can we learn
today about that?
Or what are those
things challenging
in terms of this very visual
history that centers vision
as the sole way of constructing
nature or imagining
and remembering?
And so I don't know, I was
curious to hear a little bit
more about that
from both of you,
because these things that
are engaging different parts,
different, essentially,
sensory encounters in history,
I think, challenge
existing narratives.
So I was wondering if you could
both briefly talk about that.
I don't know, Shireen, maybe.
Well, I definitely-- I
mean, that was definitely
the point of the
Zoom background,
just to show that for so many
people using these plants,
there are no illustrations
in front of them.
They're not encountering
the plant as a whole.
They're reading and memorizing.
There's a lot of
memorization involved, so
the textuality of the practice.
I didn't include too many
images of a poetic text,
but a lot of the
texts I'm looking at
are in didactic poetry so
people can memorize them.
And the inseparability
of object and text,
whether that's memorized
and oral or being read aloud
from a text, is really present.
And those were
often comparisons.
They were often about, OK,
this powder of this root
will taste slightly more
bitter than this other thing
that you will definitely
have tasted before.
And so it evokes an image of
these folks in the bazaar,
in a marketplace, just tasting
stuff and ingesting medicines
to make sure that the quality
and the identification
of the substance is correct
and it will actually
be therapeutic.
And I would like
to say that this--
some forms of this medical
tradition are still practiced,
and there definitely are people
who will keep this alive,
whether it's recognized by
post-colonial nations like
India and Pakistan
or in Bangladesh,
where Unani medicine-- is
usually what it's called
today--
is a regulated by the
state, or whether it's,
for example, in the
Middle East or in parts
of like East Africa,
or even West Africa,
this sort of tradition
is practiced.
But it's not recognized
to the same level
in most of these countries.
It's biomedicine is
medicine, and everything else
is alternative or
traditional and it does face,
because of the lack of resources
and lack of regulation,
often people are
sometimes harmed by it.
But people are harmed
by biomedicine, too.
So it's pretty
complicated, but I
would say that
there are definitely
people who continue to interact
with medicines through senses
like primarily smell and
taste more than sight.
But I also know that those who
practice this tradition today,
their education is
completely different
and often has become
biomedicalized
and that the sight
has thus become more.
But yeah, I visited
some of these schools
of Unani medicine, and
there's a laboratory of--
one of the classrooms
that I went to
had these jars of just
powders and dried roots.
And they had-- this is
like a wall of jars.
And the students who
graduate from that
need to be able to
identify each of those
without knowing
what the label says.
So there definitely are
people who still are training
in these ways of knowing.
Yeah.
I find that actually
also a really good segue
into a question that I have
for Semine's work, which
had to do with this relationship
that you briefly mentioned,
Semine, between the museum,
the garden, and the laboratory,
which there seems to be this
continuity of transformation
that happens between--
in these places that began
as experimental botanical
stations, or places for,
essentially, biolo--
essentially, a kind of
laboratory in a [INAUDIBLE]
would then become
these other things.
And I would love to hear
you talk a little bit more
about that and how it
comes about in your work.
Sure.
So the museum
buildings would often
have attached to them a
smaller botanical garden where
the people who
worked at the museums
experimented with seeds
and different plants.
And I think what we
have talked about is
that these botanical
institutions
in the colonial context
were deeply involved
with extraction and displacement
of people and importing labor.
But they were also strange
places where amateurs worked.
The British colonial offices
were not necessarily trained
or educated in biology or
botany, so a lot of them
were steered by eccentric people
who had botany as a hobby,
and a lot of the collections
were accidentally assembled.
So these collections do-- can
come across as encyclopedic.
And Shireen, you
mentioned taxonomy.
They can have this very
overwhelming and powerful
impact on you.
But they were also often
chaotic bureaucracies
with small budgets.
And when they were
then passed on to--
thinking about the
transformation, when
they were passed on
to national movements,
they became sort of a nostalgic
place for what has once been.
They were sites of abundance, of
a lost diversity, biodiversity.
So yeah, I mean,
they are strange.
The botanical gardens,
the ones in Honduras,
and the ones in
Malaysia as well,
are strange places,
because they supposedly
reflect a reality outside of
their little delineated space.
But those are usually
quite extraordinary places
with a very high diversity.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I think,
I mean, speaking--
in terms of these dilineations,
I cannot help to think about
these kind of plantation logics
that would then emerge from
these really specific
science of experimentation.
And [INAUDIBLE] particularly
that experimental station,
it basically produced a matrix
of living things, which--
plantation logic will
attempt to create hierarchies
of organisms, of life that are
embedded into these logics,
but they have a
history that comes
from all of these relationships
that have been constructed
throughout history
that are passed down
through these collections.
There's almost an
assembly line that
produces these kind of
extractive relationalities.
And so I really
find that through--
by looking at these histories
and these collections,
small collections, one is able
to almost see into the present
and perhaps extrapolate
into the future.
And-- which brings me
to another question
that I have to both of you.
I guess I don't know
if this is maybe
too much of a
positive thing, but I
was curious if you
have thoughts on what
can be learned from readings
of the vegetal imagination,
botanical history
for our present.
And can these things help
us create other imaginaries
and other relationships
to nature and to plants,
the vegetal world?
So yeah, I don't know if any of
you have any thoughts on that.
I've honestly not been
thinking about this that long.
I know there are people here
who are thoroughly plant people.
And I don't think that I've
kept a plant alive for longer
than three or four years,
so they're still alive.
But this is a relatively
recent chapter in my life,
so maybe I should
let others say.
Like I want to plug the
work of Nicholas Roth, who's
on this call, who's doing an
amazing project about botany
in early modern South
Asia across Persia and in
[INAUDIBLE],, and
he's a plant person.
He sees like a
painting, and he's like,
this this this
plant, and this is
that plant, which is awesome.
But I have been
really influenced
by Natasha Meyers' idea of
the planthroposcene and just
the idea that moving
somewhere different,
breaking the trajectory of
consumption in climate crisis
would really require tuning
into other ways of sensing
and of being.
And it's something that
I think, Nancy, you
call microbial subjectivities
and vegetal life,
which I just love.
Yeah.
But, Semine, I don't know if
you have thoughts on this.
Yeah.
I mean, Shireen, you--
your work is about medicine
and, in a way, healing.
And I want to return to the
idea of the botanical gardens
of the museums, the
colonial museums,
as kind of contradictory spaces.
The certain botanical
stations, at least
that I'm familiar
with in Malaysia,
served, for instance,
as retreat places
for Victorian English
women who had been
diagnosed with frail health.
So I think that is a curious
doubleness to the gardens.
I also think it's--
I mean, through my
little personal food
projects and Garden
Blues, it's thinking
about healing through
these places that
have done so much harm.
I don't know if that
is actually possible.
But I do think that there's
a lot of value in deepening
our knowledge
about these places,
and it gives you a
broader perspective
of how we ended up here.
Yeah.
Oh, go ahead.
No, I was going to ask Shireen
about hybridity and plant
exchanges, perhaps before
the colonial encounter,
and if you can speak to
that a little bit more.
Sure.
Yeah, I've been
really influenced
by Projit Mukharji's concept of
braided knowledge for Ayurveda,
really thinking about--
I mean, he's working
on the colonial period,
but he's pointing out that
all of the so-called "great
traditions" were already
hybrid and plural,
even when they started
to be encountered
by Europeans more frequently
from the 16th century onward.
And so definitely, it has
been fascinating for me
to be studying Ayurvedic
ideas in Persian
and the selectiveness also of
which things are translated
and which things are not.
So I think there's a different
feeling about it, because--
about those kinds of braidings
because their science
was not totalizing.
It was not implicated so deeply
in how the state governs,
and the state did
not have as invasive
a presence in the lives
of most individuals
as the modern state.
And so I feel like the
stakes of the question
are quite different than
in, say, the 19th century.
But yeah, I do really--
even though hybridity
has gotten a lot of flak
from a lot of people
for good reasons,
I think it's really important
to think about traditions
as always already hybrid.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
So we actually just got
a really great question
from Caroline Jones.
Hi, Caroline.
[LAUGHS]
Thank you so much for coming.
So it's, she asks, "I'm
curious about the gender
threads in the discussion
and Western early modernism.
Witches were the females in
command of botany and cures.
The professionalization
of curing
was a gender control
project among other things.
How does Nancy and
Semine and Shireen
see this question in the
non-Western context?"
And yeah, that is a
really great question.
I don't know if either
of you want to go first.
I definitely [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, I kind of want
to aim at you, Nancy,
because you've got a
complicated intersection here
where the colonialist--
Yeah.
--is female.
Right?
So you know, I know that
Schiebinger's work is about--
as well as Natalie Davis--
about someone like [INAUDIBLE]
going on the ships of discovery
and then talking to the women
about the abortifacients.
Yeah.
Right?
So there's a possibility
of intersectionality there
that's interesting.
But in your different
contexts, right, it
might just be canceled out.
And for Shireen,
I'm also inspired
by the work of the HTC
PhD student, [INAUDIBLE]..
Maybe you know her.
Anyway, she's working on poison
manuals, which are always
written by men about
women as the ones who
have to hold the potion or to
put some of their urine in it.
It's very wet wrapped
through the female world
of these Islamic medieval
texts she's looking at,
these poison manuals.
But the women are not
doing the writing.
So anyway, it's just
a grab bag question,
but I'd love to know
what you all think
about these flows of power.
Yeah, absolutely.
I would like to address
the question of Dorothy,
which is one that--
Caroline, you were there at the
very beginning of this inquiry,
and I will have to
admit that I don't think
I have arrived to a
conclusion of what
my relationship to this
character, Dorothy,
specifically is.
It's a very complicated one.
It's an acknowledgment
that she, in her--
she essentially helped
perpetrate and spread
a very specific
kind of violence,
while at the same time
producing knowledge
that was, at the time,
considered perhaps
maybe forbidden or--
I think that, in some
ways, the question
of the control of gender
is really interesting,
and it brings me, maybe,
to think about maybe
more about the present,
because I think that there have
definitely been a sort of
revival of these practices
that are perhaps considered
maybe pseudo-science.
Or there's been this
revival of herbalism
and, essentially, witchcraft.
And I believe that
it has transcended,
in some ways,
gender, and we have
a new vision of
this relationship
to magic and the occult, and
which is deeply, deeply related
to these botanical
relationships, what
that might look like today.
And I don't know, I feel
that, Semine, I really
hear what you talked about with
this idea of healing and curing
and that knowledge was--
this kind of botanical
knowledge was also,
in some ways, gendered, or
this way of being in the garden
was specifically also--
yeah, very pointed.
Yeah, sorry, I'm
getting all tongue tied.
But yeah, Caroline, I feel
like it's complicated,
and I don't think I've arrived
to any kind of conclusion
or terminal point.
Good artistic position.
Yeah, I mean, thank you so
much for this reference.
I'm going to follow
up for the name
of the scholar you mentioned.
I'd also like to point to Sara
Verskin's book, Barren Women,
which just came out last year.
And it's really
interesting, because she
is deeply interested in
women's knowledge and women's
experiences.
But her sources from the
medieval Islamic world
are all written by men.
And I believe she's
primarily working in Arabic.
She also reads some
Hebrew sources as well.
But what really comes through
from that book, something
I'm really taking away
from it, is the intensity
of male anxieties around women's
knowledge and women's spaces.
And it's just astounding
sometimes to read,
especially legal scholars,
not as much physicians,
but intensely for
legal scholars,
Islamic religious scholars,
ulema, how they are concerned.
And they're not concerned
about witchcraft and magic
explicitly.
But what they are
concerned about
is that they have
the real Islam.
They have the proper and
textual Islam as male scholars.
And when women get
together, especially
around intense moments of life
and transition like birth,
they don't know what kind of
practices they're transmitting,
and they don't want that to
happen without somebody being
there, some man being there
saying what the real Islam is.
And so I think
that, unfortunately,
as became clear to
me reading this book,
there aren't always
going to be questions
that we can answer about what
women's spaces looked like
and what their knowledge
looked like in this period,
just because they were, except
in particular disciplines,
like hadith
prophetic traditions,
they were largely excluded
from textual production.
So yeah, it's been hard to
grapple with that with reading
that book this year.
Yeah.
I think Semine also had a
comment on this before we
wrap up, as we're very close.
But do you want
to go ahead and--
Yeah.
I can share my thought briefly.
So I think it's a really
interesting question,
because a lot of the colonial
officers and civil servants
that I look at, and who
left behind the archive
at the colonial
museums, were men.
But the travelogues, there
are quite a few travelogues
of Victorian women who traveled
across the British empire
and met all of
these civil servants
and documented
their conversations
and described their
character and how
they interacted with the
locals, their relationship
with the locals.
So in a way, this
travelogues for me
was this more like backstage
human relationship,
what's going on between
the colonial officers.
They were written by these
women who were very wealthy,
and they spent their life
just traveling around.
But yeah, I think that's,
at least in the texts
that I've encountered,
there's a different category
of text that women
would have written,
a travelogue or
botanical illustrations.
And those travelogues
is one of them
that is specifically speaks
to the gender question, yeah,
you are raising.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it's also interesting.
I mean, a lot of botanical
illustrators were women.
And it was-- for example, in
my project [INAUDIBLE] project,
Dorothy Popenoe produced
a lot of the illustrations
that Wilson Popenoe,
her husband,
who was a really famous
botanist, published.
And it was this labor of
reproducing this knowledge that
was still almost
blanketed and obscured
by the almost monumentalizing
of Wilson Popenoe's career.
And so-- OK, Sarah just
gave me the little signal
that we're very close
to wrapping up tonight.
But if anyone would like to
stay afterwards and ask any more
questions, you're
more than welcome to.
But I wanted to say thank
you also to everyone who came
and to Semine and Shireen.
So if you would like to stay
and ask a couple more questions,
you're more than welcome to.
But if you have to
go, also no worries.
But thank you so much, Sarah
and the Wiesner Gallery
for opening up this
opportunity and this space
for having this really amazing
conversation with these two
historians and also artists in
their own right whose work I
deeply admire.
So thank you very much,
everyone, and yeah,
hopefully see soon.
Thank you so much to
our amazing panelists.
Yes, and those friends who
want to stay, you're welcome.
But really, we appreciate
everyone's participation.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hi, Nicholas.
This is just sort of
bundle of questions.
I'm not sure how
useful it is but--
and how much is just
my own concerns.
But one thing that I
was wondering about is,
as we were just talking about
colonial imperial contexts writ
large, and as opposed to a
pre-colonial or non-colonial
context with your work, Shireen,
I wonder to what degree you
think that there are
peculiarities and whether they
matter to botanical science
as implemented or as promoted
by particular Western colonial,
quote, unquote, "cultures,"
particular empires, especially
with the obsessive centrality
to British imperial identity
that botany is for the Brits,
to the point even
where they weren't--
where British partners
are, and lady travelers who
produce botanic illustrations
are all over the place,
even in colonies that
aren't historically British.
Mm-hmm.
And that-- and there's this
particular pattern that
has been relatively well
studied and documented
of gardens in particular
British colonies,
like Malaya, like
India, and that end up
having particular relationships
to the local elites
and their production of
knowledge around this stuff,
versus other European
empires, where
I think we have a comparatively
more spottier record.
I mean, Shireen mentioned
Daniela Bleeichmar's work
on botany in the
Iberian colonial world.
But there-- do those differences
and those dynamics matter?
I was also just thinking that
with the-- we have so many--
in a anglophone
slash Germanic world
from early on, with
Marion and so on,
we have all these
women producing
botanical illustration.
But for the Spanish
imperial expeditions,
we have indigenous Mexican
artists, who are men
but who are Mexican
born and Mestizo.
Are there parallels
or connections there?
I don't know, just bundle of
questions that might or might
not be useful.
Can I add one question,
Nicholas, since you're--
Yes.
--here?
Which is, how do you think
about gender in botany
in your work in early
modern South Asia?
I haven't engaged with
it very thoroughly so far
because the working of 16th
through 18th century South
Asian sources, I have so few
female voices in the record.
So where I've touched
upon it has merely mostly
been in regard in the way
that horticultural spaces
and horticultural
labor is imagined.
And there, women feature, I
think, relatively prominently,
but almost to the point of
it being a poetic conc--
sort of a literary
conceit, I think.
But this is always with
the caveat that these are
the imaginings or
ideals of male authors,
at least in the work that I've--
materials I've looked
at so far and patterns
that I've looked at so far.
Thank you so much,
Nicholas, for that question.
I'm an artist, and so
I feel like I'm not
qualified to answer any
of that [INAUDIBLE]..
But, Semine, I don't know if you
have an answer or a response,
or if anyone would
also like to follow up
with another question,
you're more than
welcome to unmute
yourself and also ask one.
I think what came to mind--
I think this is more a
response than an answer.
The botanical stations
and the hill stations
that I'm familiar with were
both experimental gardens
where British colonial
officers in Malaysia
collected species from across
the empire and also territories
beyond.
But they were at the same time
also little miniature versions
of British gardens.
So I think this comes back to,
yeah, the contradictory spaces
that these places are.
It's both a place of
foreign, quote, unquote,
"foreign" imported
seeds and plants.
But they were also
green spaces where
I think the British
made themselves
feel at ease or at home.
Like rose gardens were
built next to experiments
with tobacco and
silk and especially
in the hills where
the climate was more
suitable for European plants.
Yeah, so there's the strange
coexistence in these gardens.
Yeah, that's a comment I
think for you, Nicholas.
Wow.
That just reminds me of--
I'm not super versed
in the scholarship,
but the production of Persian
gardens all over South
Asia and the post 14th century
explosion of these forms, yeah,
we actually have an expert
here to talk about that.
But yeah, I think that that--
I'm trying to grapple with the
part of Nick's question, which
is like, what is
the distinction,
say, for example, between the
expansion of Persian style
gardens under the
sultanate into South Asia
and the kind of British gardens
you're talking about, Semine.
And I feel like it
really comes down
to both labor and epistemology.
It can't just be,
oh, the exportation
of like ideas and aesthetics.
It really also has to do
with the very unique kinds
of racialized forms
of labor that emerge,
I think, in European empire.
And I just I don't think that--
though there are certainly
social hierarchies
in all parts of the
world, and caste
deserves mention for sure for
South Asia, they're just not--
I think yeah, that shifts
as well in the modern.
And I feel like I
always come back
to labor when I'm
trying to say what's
the difference between premodern
and modern empire labor,
and as well as just the totality
of scientific discourses.
Some of the-- like you
were saying, Nicholas,
what do we do with these
idealized representations
of women, for example, or of
specific groups or subgroups
of people by elite writers?
Well, those things
they were producing
didn't actually
transform into policy.
They didn't become
an imperial apparatus
that then governed those
people's lives, at least not
immediately or not
in a total way.
So I feel like that's
a difference, too.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Yeah, I guess one thing I
was also thinking about,
maybe to bring it to a
completely different scale
and maybe direction
is, in some ways,
I think these kind of legacies
of plant representation and--
I think a lot about, I
think, history of photography
as being deeply entangled
with the history
of botanical representation
and illustration.
And in some ways,
I feel that it's
this pursuit of chlorophyll,
of light, of greenness
that led to the creation
of a lot of technologies
of vision, of visualization,
of preservation.
And that has been
a really central--
yeah, just a central theme
for some of my practice, and I
feel it's underlying a
lot of these questions
of colonial networks
of exchange and what
was the driving force behind
a lot of these exchanges
and transportations.
And I don't want to
forget about, I guess,
the plants themselves,
the vegetal agency
and who is actually
cultivating whom?
Was it humans who were
actually the drivers
of these exchanges--
Wow.
--or did plants
themselves cultivate us?
It's important to move whose
desires are we looking at.
And so that is a
kind of question
that I've been thinking
about for a while, which
I don't know--
we're running way
over time, but I just
wanted to bring that
to the conversation.
But I think maybe this is
a good time to wrap it up.
I wanted to thank
everyone again.
Sarah, thank you so
much for everything.
Semine and Shireen, I am
so grateful and so inspired
by both of you, and I
hope that we can continue
this conversation further.
And I'm really looking
forward to see what
else you guys are working on.
And thank you,
everyone, for being here
and have a good night.